so arkansas is one of the most
conservative states in the country how
do you know that we just poll the people
who live there what they think about the
various issues but like a lot of
conservative states arkansas is governed
by some very liberal republicans
so jake beckett is not one of them he's
running for senate in the primary as a
republican in the state of arkansas and
it looks like not everyone is for that
so for several weeks jake beckett's
first name was completely wrong on
thousands of ballots now that's a
problem for him because another
candidate with the same last name
beckett is also on the ballot election
officials told us to say they have fixed
the problem but voties has already
started in the arkansas primary now jake
beckett is suing
we thought this was interesting so we
asked him to come on and explain what's
happening to us jake thanks so much for
coming on um it's hard not to see me and
maybe you don't want to say this out
loud but from an outsider's perspective
it almost seems like sabotage
by your own party
well i'll say it sucker here in arkansas
we have a lot of republicans but not
very many conservative warriors yes and
that's who i am at my core
i'm a warrior and what the
establishment's lined up against me they
have four or five super pacs running
non-stop attack ads there's probably one
coming up in your next commercial break
here in arkansas but what happened is
early voting started on monday and we
discovered we had outraged voters from
multiple arkansas counties reaching out
to me with screenshots of the ballot
boxes and these voting machines my name
was wrong it said jack beckett instead
of jake beckett so we reached out to
these counties and we expected they'd be
surprised you know that oh my gosh the
the ballots are wrong no they knew
tucker we have proof they admitted that
for three weeks before early voting
started they knew my name was going to
be wrong and said nothing in violation
of arkansas state law so look here's
what happened tucker they thought i was
part of the old right they thought they
i was one of these establishment rhinos
who was just going to take it lying down
say okay you know all shucks we'll get
them next time no tucker i punched back
i'm going to do business as business is
being done i'm part of the new right we
filed lawsuits we took him to court
today in court the judge said this whole
situation was deeply troubling and all
of a sudden tucker voila they started
fixing these voting machines and these
ballots they originally told us in a lie
were unfixable so we already got them oh
we've already got them on the runtucker
here in arkansas they've already fixed
them in one candy we're going to make
sure they didn't verify you know as
reagan said trust but verify we skipped
the trust we're going straight to verify
we're going to make sure on monday that
all 75 arkansas counties have the
correct name on the ballot that's jake
beckett for u.s senate not jack but even
if it says jack vote for jack because
look i'm not going to dc to be a part of
the establishment regime the uniparty
i'm a conservative warrior i'm going to
fight for the citizens of arkansas on
election integrity because look tucker
at the end of the day this should not be
a partisan issue election integrity look
if you have the courage to put your name
on the ballot to run if you love your
country enough to run for office and
serve our country if you're republican
democrat green party who cares i don't
care what office you're seeking u.s
senate or dog catcher you deserve to
have the voters be fully informed be
fully enfranchised and know who they're
voting for so when i win this race
tucker when i win this primary win this
runoff if necessary and go to the u.s
senate i'm going to turn the guns of the
arkansas rhino establishment word i'm
going to fix this once and for all and
i'm going to make sure arkansas has
secure elections
yeah and and politicians who represent
the people of arkansas you know asa
hosts does not represent your average
arkansas republican sorry i don't get
anywhere jake beckett i appreciate you
coming on tonight godspeed
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight